i work with zulu p and they are a rap
group here in new york city
they've played shows all over new york
at this point the group consists of the
founding member marly g i'm the great
molly jake sweetness like a sunshine
t-rock my microphone came out every node
and little eb
and peace
they have a really original take on
hip-hop
we have a program here that serves
adults with developmental disabilities
who also play music
they don't seem to develop
preconceptions about how things should
be
definitely musically
it's a really striking kind of freedom i
think for people who
live their lives guided by and sometimes
bounded by other people's perceptions or
preconceptions
we just booked zulu p on shows like you
would book any regular band and don't
give any type of preface or anything
people will come they'll see the show
but you can see that there's a little
tension there for people but i think
it's a productive and interesting
tension
the members of zulu p are completely
open totally positive always down
they're not cynical and they're never
self-conscious
ow
it's really amazing to see them get up
there and crush a show